نحن هنا بمركز مدينه سقطت مجموعه من
القذائف هذا الصباح وهذه اثار القذائف
التي نزلت هذا الصباح نشاهد كما تبرز
الصوره تدمير عدد من السيارات بالاضافه
الى تدمير شاحنه بالكامل حيث سقطت القذيفه
على الشاحنه ادت الى سقوط قتلى في هذا
الحادث لكن لحد الساعه لم يعلم عدد القتلى
الذين سقطوا المعلومات الاوليه تشير على
ان مجموع القذائف التي وجهت الى مركز
مدينه يصل الى اربعه صواريخ تم اعتراض
ثلاثه منها من قبل مضادات الدفاع الجويه
لكن احدى هذه القذائف سقطت في هذه المنطقه
واسفرت عن سقوط ضحايا وعن تدمير هذا الباص
باكمله بالاضافه الى السياره هناك تم نقل
الجثث والجرحى الى المستشفيات لكن كما
اسلفنا غير معروف لحد الساعه عدد الضحايا
الذين سقطوا
في هذا الحادث الذي استهدف صباح هذا اليوم
وسط مدينه
الدغير الجزيره دونيت